all right Christian well this is such an
exciting time for you new team tell me
what you see when you look at AC Milan
yeah thanks for having me I'm uh I mean
I just see a historic Club
um obviously one with with lots of
trophies and uh just the team that you
know that I you know watched growing up
with a bunch of Legends coming out of
this club and uh yeah I'm just really
excited to be here
something that you would mention a few
times in your press conference is you
just talking about you know your
potential the heights you want to reach
the level that you want to hit how close
are you to becoming that player that you
want to become
yeah I think I think I'm close to to
where I want to be I think the level
that I'm at is uh I think I have the
ability to um you know to reach those
levels and now it's just about showing
it and showing it you know consistently
you know week week in week out and you
know have a great opportunity to do so
now
you've also been really impressive just
in the short time that you have been
there up to this point what is it felt
like for you out there
it's a it's amazing it feels like a
fresh start obviously you know coming to
a new club a new country
it really is kind of a new beginning for
me and I'm I'm just really excited to to
have this opportunity and to get to you
know showcase it for for such a big club
like Milan
now your new manager Stefano Pioli he
has been raving about how impressed he
is with you already in such a short time
and when you were discussing him you
said that he made you feel like he
wanted you there how does having that
real Confidence from your manager also
enhance your performance as well
yeah it's super important I think when
you have that trust you know from your
teammates from the club from the manager
it really does give you a lot of
confidence and just allows you to be
yourself and you know use the qualities
that that you know you have you know
that what's got you here and you know
they see they see that in you and they
want that to be a part of their team so
for me it just gives me that that extra
confidence to express myself and to uh
yeah hopefully you know play really well
for these colors
you know many potential options but what
is it about AC Milan that enticed you
the most what did you hear from them
that really resonated
yeah I think it's it's what you said I
think I did have that feeling like I was
wanted at this club and they wanted the
qualities that I bring you know at this
club I think I obviously know some of
the guys on the team as well which is
awesome and that's a great you know help
when you first start and uh yeah I guess
a lot of reasons all the timing and and
it all just lined up and this this
really felt like the right decision
now about a year ago you did a YouTube
video and some fans had questions for
you and somebody asked are you better on
the wing or in the middle and you said
that you liked both it just depended on
the style the team that you are with so
I'm going to ask you now do you think
that you're better on the wing or in the
middle
yeah that's a good question I think
I think you know it being just my first
week here I've been playing more you
know more on the wing which I feel very
comfortable in but I think you know
we'll see I'll get some opportunities
potentially in different positions in
these couple preseason games and I think
I'll definitely be able to give you uh
you know a better answer in a couple
weeks time
good so how do you like to play and how
does that fit the style there
yeah so for me I think I'm just a very
um you know very direct very aggressive
creative player I like to go you know
straight to goal and just keep you know
keep the other team on their own you
know on their heels and uh you know make
you know cause problems in that sense I
like to score goals and create you know
assists and
um that's definitely what I bring and I
wanna I think that's you know reason why
they brought me here and I hope that I
can showcase you know those skills um
for this club
when you were just talking about what it
is like for you to be there you use the
term fresh start and I think that's
great how has that felt for you mentally
to be in a place where it feels like
such a fresh start
yeah I think I'm in a great place
um mentally I think
um you know there was definitely some
ups and downs in my recent years of my
previous Club some great memories that
I'll take with me but I'm definitely
excited about this about this fresh
start and uh yeah I think it's just um
I don't know it's it's a new opportunity
to uh to you know become you know an
important member of this team and
hopefully you know be a regular and um
you know get lots of minutes and uh you
know be a big part of this team moving
forward
absolutely and we have you know we've
moved on to New Opportunities so I don't
want to harp on your past too much but
there is one quote that I want to ask
you about because I thought it was
really interesting when discussing your
time with Chelsea and what you're doing
now with AC Milan you said it's a new
opportunity and for me in recent years I
haven't gotten the opportunity I wanted
and haven't reached the level that I
want to be at what is the opportunity
that you feel like you got and what's
the opportunity that you wanted
yeah I think
um you know what I what I want is of
course is regular game time which of
course you have to earn
um and uh you know I'm gonna do my best
to you know to train hard and play well
and hopefully earn earn more time here
and uh
it's not to say that um
you know I'm you know I'm complaining or
anything about you know in the previous
years why I wasn't why I wasn't playing
or this or that but now I have a fresh
opportunity and I really want to just go
after it because as players
um it's why we do what we do we want to
be on that field and and we want to play
because we're very competitive is there
anything that you're looking to prove
with AC Milan that you maybe weren't
able to any other time
I think I think um for me it's it's more
so about consistency it's being that um
you know that player that can constantly
you know create goals and be a big part
of the team and doing that consistently
I think I had great Spurs of it in you
know in uh in London and some really
great moments but just uh just doing it
doing it week in week out like I said
amazing okay well switching gear just a
little bit I don't know if you can see
this photo I know you're familiar with
the photo but it is you when you are in
the hospital bed the Snapchat filter
tell me the story of this photo from
your point of view
hmm yeah that photo wasn't really
supposed to get out but uh from my point
of view
um I I went straight to the hospital
like at halftime of that you know of
that game
um which I was all kind of in a bit of
shock in that moment I didn't really
know what was going on
um but as I went there I was streaming
it on one of our you know one of our
physio's phones and he was I was
watching the game and we were just
watching anxiously just waiting for that
final whistle and once it went off the
emotions were were massive for me it was
a huge win for our country and
just a really proud moment obviously you
can see my emotions there yeah no it is
a great photo and it was such like a
nice viral moment online at that time
but I'm so curious so the photo wasn't
supposed to go out you were sending it
to what friends teammates family and
then what happened I think I I think I
just put that on one of my like I don't
know private stores or something and it
yeah it got out somewhere but I don't
really know a story hey it could be
worse because at least that was a great
moment I love that photo
um but speaking of the U.S Men's
National Team okay scale of one to ten
how excited were you when you found out
that you all were gonna have Flo ball
again yeah we were we were thrilled of
course obviously he had you know such a
successful season and uh he just brings
so much so much to our team and he's
just such a talented player so obviously
just phenomenal and you know going to be
a big part of our team moving forward so
it was great to have him and you know he
already was able to impact the game and
score and yeah we love having him
and he could have played elsewhere so
what do you think it says about the
future of the U.S Men's National Team
that they were able to draw him
I mean I think it speaks for how far
this team has come you know in the last
you know in the last recent years
um but uh
I think I think we're going to be a real
Force you know moving into these next
competitions and going into the next
World Cup I think people have already
seen you know we've shocked a lot of
people and really changed the view
um of the way you know people see
American soccer and uh obviously you
know after a pretty strong World Cup
um you know he probably saw you know a
young a hungry team one that's uh has a
lot of talent and uh you know he's he's
just going to help that along
what conversations have you had with him
if any about what you all could
potentially accomplish
yes so
um I mean speaking with him right away
from that first camp we know what's
ahead of us we you know we we obviously
we're taking a game by game we wanted to
win this Nations league and uh yeah the
next step is obviously you know Copa
America coming up and then the World Cup
I think we want to go in advance as far
as we can and we want to win trophies
and you know we want to win major
competitions so that's that's the next
step for us
amazing well we of course will all be
rooting for you all to do just that I
want to take a moment to celebrate Megan
rapino obviously an absolute Legend how
has her presence impacted U.S soccer
generally
yeah well I think uh you know a lot of
people look up look up to her and uh not
just her but the whole women's team
um you know I just arrived on uh on a
long flight and as soon as I landed I
was tuned in watching the you know their
game yesterday
um watching uh watching the women play
and uh obviously they've been you know
so successful so it's uh it just brings
a lot of Buzz around the game and uh you
know Americans definitely love watching
World Cup so it's it's definitely
exciting being here as well during this
time and uh yeah excited to follow them
and hoping they can uh they can you know
hopefully win it again yeah certainly a
lot of amazing soccer has been on lately
I'm sure you if you weren't watching the
actual game you saw Messi's goal and his
debut in Miami what did you just realize
about Messi's greatness in that moment
because it was crazy
yeah definitely it's just like one of
those things where you see it and it's
just like of course it happened that way
you know it's just like it almost
doesn't surprise you anymore I mean what
what you know what we've seen from him
in the past you know decade even more um
you know what he's accomplished what he
continues to do the World Cup finally
and now him coming in like that and uh
you know seeing all the you know the
stars watching him play and him coming
in and scoring like that it really just
doesn't surprise me anymore but uh it's
still special nonetheless just watching
him
um just creating Magic on the field
always so it's pretty cool to have him
here in this country as well and I know
a lot of people are excited about that
what did people not realize about just
how hard what he did was
I mean it's not easy to score every kick
like that in the last minute
um I mean it's just I'm sure it's
something that he's just practiced over
and over and over again and for him um
you know he's so he's so used to the big
moments and uh you know for him that's
that's probably nothing
I love it your mom shared a story about
you when you were two years old that I
was reading about she said that when you
were coloring you would go out of the
lines it would frustrate you so much
that she had to buy you white out for
you to continue to color what do you
think that says about maybe your want
for perfect for Perfection and does that
one for for Perfection still bleed into
your adult life
yeah
um I I've definitely always been that
way
um
it definitely it definitely has stuck
with me I think it's a big part of why
you know why I've been you know
successful and
um it's also you know maybe something
that holds me back because I I
constantly
um you know push to be you know to be a
perfectionist to be to be the best I can
be
um and uh that's always going to be just
a part of a part of who I am yeah I mean
I love that you're two years old and you
don't want to be outside the lines
um and I think that in a lot of ways you
know soccer players are incredibly
fascinating to me because so early in
your life it feels like there's always
so many expectations and you start this
so incredibly early how did this sport
almost shape not necessarily your
identity but how you view everything
else if that makes sense
yeah that's a big question I think uh I
think it's just been a part of my life
ever since I can remember
um I've Loved this game obviously since
I was a kid and it is definitely you
know kind of molded me into into who I
am it's been a part of my life you know
as long as I can remember I've learned a
lot of lessons just you know being in a
team with all different kinds of coaches
and playing in all different countries
and all different styles of the game
it's definitely it's definitely shaped
me you know to who I you know into who I
am today
um
yeah I don't really know how else to to
answer that question but but just to say
it's been it's been it's been in every
step of my life so it's uh it's just
become so prominent in my life that it's
just like second nature for me it's it's
my personal life and it's the soccer
it's right there yeah you mentioned how
you think maybe a perfectionism bleeds
into things a little bit now in what
ways do you have any examples
I mean you know I can just think of it
in the way that I train you know over
the summer
um you know obviously I take a few days
off and then I'm right back into it and
I'm working on things over and over and
over until I get it right consistently
that's just uh that's the way that I
work and if I do it wrong I'm never
going to end like that it's got to be
right it's got to be you know I got to
do it the right way you know
consistently and then once I'm feeling
good about it then I can then I can kind
of move on
okay so right now what are you working
on mentally and what are you working on
physically you know mentally I think
I think I'm trying to
um kind of really jump into this new
culture with this new move I think you
know it's very easy to kind of stick to
what you know and and try to uh
um just just get by and you know
obviously I'm naturally just an
introverted person so I think what I'm
trying to do is go a little bit outside
of my comfort zone and kind of open up
and just try a bunch of new things and
be open to this new change for me that's
that's definitely what I'm doing and
then obviously physically is uh is
getting myself fit 100 ready to go for
this season so that once the games come
around I'll be you know hopefully ready
to be you know to run 90 minutes
11 and I also saw you working on your
Italian how's that going we form in
sentences yeah we're we're working on it
um I haven't I'll start more lessons
once I'm back in Italy now but I've
definitely already started on some of
the apps and uh I'm gonna I'm gonna do
my best to learn
amazing all right last one for you uh if
your life was a book and it had chapters
what would you title this chapter that
you're in right now
hmm I I guess
I guess we could use like what we said
before with kind of just like a fresh
start uh would be it would be a good
term
um
yeah well I'll keep it simple I'll go
with that I love that Fresh Start well
you were a joy thank you so much for
your time
um I would be remiss if I did not thank
our dear friend Urban for all the help
that he gave me answering all my soccer
questions uh but this was so great and I
look forward to watching you
thank you so much thanks for having me
foreign
[Music]